-Martha,
welcome back to the show.
-Thank you.
-It's always great
to have you on.
Thanks for playing "Charades"
with me and being my partner.
I appreciate it.
-It was so much fun.
-I want to talk about --
There's so many things.
By the way, I never know
if I thanked you for this,
but do you remember
when I ran into you at a farm?
-Out in the Hamptons?
-Yeah.
-And you taught me
how to pickle,
and you got me into pickling.
And I made pickles.
I was --
-I was so happy
that you wanted to pickle.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that right?
-So happy.
-I was at this farm --
Fairview Farms.
Harry is the owner there,
the farmer there.
I love him.
-They're the ones who deep-fry
the sweet potatoes
and all the -- and the red
potatoes and the blue potatoes.
-It's so delicious.
I just love the whole family,
the vibe, and I'm there,
and I go,
"Harry, how do you make -- do
you have any pickle recipes?
Or how do you --"
He goes, "I don't really know,
but she would be
the perfect person to ask."
I turn around,
and Martha Stewart is at the --
picking vegetables
at the garden.
I go, "This is like a dream.
This is like unbelievable."
[ Laughter ]
-You're such a good student.
You know, you just
pick it up right away.
And you have a good memory, too.
Because you remembered
how to make them.
-I did, and I loved them.
-I should have brought you
my newest pickles.
I'll send you a jar.
-Oh, my God.
-Little tiny
red and yellow peppers.
Pequeño peppers.
-That's perfect.
See? Come on.
I want to talk about --
You have a show this weekend
on HGTV called "Table Wars."
-Oh, yeah.
-You -- That's a giant thing.
Then you're starting Martha.com.
Different than
MarthaStewart.com.
This is Martha.com.
-Yes.
Yeah, this is our online store
with all our things,
things that I design,
things that I curate...
-It's so impressive.
-...things that we find
here and there.
And it's a really, really
wonderful website.
And so it answers
all your needs.
If you're a homemaker and you
need stuff for your kitchen
or your bedrooms,
your bathrooms, it's there.
But if you need gifts,
they're there.
-Yeah. You have flannel sheets
on there, I saw.
I really checked it out.
You have NFTs
you're selling on there.
-Oh, the best.
The best.
And, you know,
I was so surprised, because,
you know, everybody started
getting into the NFTs,
nonfungible...
-Tokens, yeah.
-...tokens, you know.
And you can pay with the
cryptocurrency or without.
One of ours, the naughty nurse
picture of me for Halloween,
sold for a lot.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
-I was thinking --
Because you always have
these new ideas.
I always thought
maybe I'd pitch you an idea,
and maybe we could get into
business together.
-Let me hear.
-Okay. Ready for this?
-This is like "Shark Tank."
I've always wanted to be
on "Shark Tank."
-Oh, yeah, me too.
-Yeah.
-All right, ready?
This one, here we go.
We can go fast or slow
if you want.
Pre-made cranberry slices,
almost like Kraft cheese,
but it's just cranberry slices.
You throw it on a turkey
sandwich with stuffing,
and it's a post-Thanksgiving...
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, all right.
Hey, don't worry --
Hey, don't worry about it.
I got a lot of -- tons of ideas.
-How do you package them?
They're messy.
Make your own cranberry sauce
and just put a nice little
spoon of it on each sandwich.
-Sandwich?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, turkey sandwiches
the day after.
-I know, but now you just said
"sandwich,"
but before, you said,
"sandwhich."
-"Sandwhich."
[ Light laughter ]
-Are you ready for this, Martha?
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, we're having a sandwhich."
Martha, how about this?
Ready for this?
-With stuffing! Don't forget
the stuffing on the sandwich.
-I know, the stuffing.
Um, cookie bread.
-Cookie bread.
Like what?
What do you mean?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, they're in for it.
They're into it.
-I'm enjoying
your reaction because --
-Cookie bread.
-Yeah, so why does
cinnamon toast
have the only sweet bread
that you can get out there?
Why not different flavors
of sweet breads, like,
that taste like sugar cookies
or peppermint cookies
or chocolate chip?
-Why not just eat the cookies?
[ Laughter ]
-You always want, like,
something different.
Okay.
You don't like that.
All right, last idea.
How about coffee mugs
where, if you put them
on the holder,
a little air blows through
the bottom of them
and just keeps it
stirring around.
[ Light laughter ]
-Stirring what?
-No.
-Someone just yelled, "No."
[ Laughter ]
Well, if you use
an alternative milk like
a nut milk or something --
-But, see, I don't like mugs.
I think mugs are sort of
clumsy and ugly.
[ Laughter ]
I don't own a mug in my house.
-Really?
-No. I have beautiful cups.
-We give you mugs every time
you're on our show.
-I know, but I give them away.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, if you guys want our mugs
or anything, go to Martha.com.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everything holiday.
Check it out.
Recipes.
You'll just love every
single thing on this thing.
Tune in for the premiere
of "Table Wars"
this Sunday night
at 8:00 p.m., on HGTV.